Hello, and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
Live at the Rawkode Academy.
I am your host Rawkode,
and I always kick myself for saying Rawkode
three times in such quick succession.
However, today we are taking a look at
the cloud native API gateway take. I'm really
excited to take a look at this project.
It brings a lot of features and functionality
to your cloud native architectures,
and we'll dive into that in just a
minute.
A little bit of housekeeping. If you're not
already subscribed to the channel, now would be
a really good time to click that button,
and feel free to click the bell to
get notifications for all new episodes.
I'd also like to encourage you to like,
comment, and share these videos to help other
people discover them. There are also membership packages
available at the academy starting as little as
$1 per month that allow you to support
this channel and all the content that is
being produced.
If you wanna continue your learning outside of
these videos, we have a rather active Discord
server where we talk about all things, cloud
native, Kubernetes, eBPF,
and everything in between.
So come and say hello, and I look
forward to meeting you.
Alright. To guide us on our journey today
into the Tyk API Gateway, I am joined
by Andy and Budap from a Tyk team.
Hi, both. How are you doing today?
Hey. Good. Thanks. Thank you for having us.
Well, thank you very much for joining me
today. It's gonna be a lot of fun
kicking the tires on this and seeing what
we can do with Tyk.
For anyone that is not familiar with yourselves,
could you please just do as an honor
of saying hello and introducing yourself? And we'll
start with you, Andy, on the left.
Yeah. Hi, everyone. I'm a
solutions architect at Tyk. I've been here for
somewhere between eighteen months and two years now.
So, yeah, I've been working in API management
a little while and, before that, quite a
bit of experience in
integration generally.
Thank you very much for sharing. And Buddha?
Hello, everyone. I am Buddha. I am a
product evangelist at Tyk, and I'm joining you
today from Singapore.
And just like Andy, actually, both of us,
we joined almost at the same time about
eighteen months ago, coincidentally
almost. And it so happened that we also
joined in right at the at the start
of the pandemic. So before I was done.
Unfortunately, we yeah.
Before it all went to hell, we joined
the company. So
but but it's been it's been quite fantastic
learning more about
API management. I think I've I've had worked
with APIs before,
but my journey into the world of API
management and what that entails with the API
gateways and all of the other things around
security and that abstraction, which we'll be talking
about today,
has been really, really fascinating to learn about.
And, that's that's fundamentally changed my perspective in
terms of how I would architect API based
solutions now. So, hopefully, that'll be something of
interest to people who are listening today as
well. So, yeah, looking forward to the session.
Alright. Thank you very much. And I I
like that you say you both joined the
company at the start of the pandemic. I
also changed job at the start of the
pandemic. And as such, I haven't actually met
most of my team, like, ever, which is
a
that was pretty crap. Right? You wanna be
able to meet up and and do the
on sites and stuff. But hopefully, things are
getting better now.
Absolutely. That's that's been exactly the thing. Because
when I joined, I think at that point,
Singapore was still okay, but they I think
Singapore was early in terms of going into
lockdowns.
So
I think as soon as I joined after
a couple of weeks, that was that was
the that was it. So work from home
was the norm pretty much.
So we've not ended up meeting either. So
fingers crossed, we'll we'll get that opportunity soon
enough. Yeah.
I think Singapore has done well. I don't
want us to try and test you about
the pandemic. Right? And I'm definitely not gonna
rant about The UK's handling of it, but
I do believe Singapore has done alright. So
that's good. Anyway,
I think we've got some slides from you,
Bitter. Right? You're gonna introduce us to to
Tyk, and then I'll do my best to
get some questions across to you as we
go. So if you wanna get your screen
prepared and to the audience, I would encourage
you to ask your questions. Drop them into
the chat, and I'll do my best to
relay them on to Andy and put it
as we go.
Okay.
Your screen is live.
Yeah. Take it away. I'll jump. Fantastic.
Okay. Yeah. So I thought I'll give a
quick introduction. These are just a few slides.
And when I say few, it's about six
or seven slides,
just to sort of set the scene for
today so that you understand a a little
bit about, what we do, really, and who
we are. So,
going into the world of cloud native API
management,
just a little bit about us, about Tyk,
how we began. We started off as an
open source project actually all the way back
in 02/2014.
Our founder, Martin, he pretty much was looking
for a solution. He found a couple of
them not particularly to his liking, so he
decided to just build one over a weekend.
And that project
gained some traction as he kept adding on
things to it. And eventually, we got to
commercializing the product in 02/2016.
So it's been a pretty solid journey over
the last, I think, about five years now
overall.
And
we've built our team pretty strongly over the
few years. And right now, I think we
have crossed our hundred team members mark,
and we are remote first. So I think
we were remote first before the pandemic hit.
So I think this has pretty much been
a norm for us in terms of working
styles.
Even though we do have offices in three
different locations at the moment, UK, Singapore, and
Atlanta in The United States, these are the
three main offices, but we have team members
in 27 different countries, I believe, at the
moment.
And so so we we could keep in
touch completely remotely anyway. So we are remote
first.
A little bit about the platform itself, and,
obviously, there there are a lot of things
that I can go on about. I think
we'll be demonstrating some of those things today,
but I I picked out a couple of
them which I thought might be useful for
people to know more about.
And that was firstly
that we are platform agnostic. What does that
mean?
We are an independent API management platform, which
means that we are not tied to any
particular ecosystem.
We are pretty much neutral when it comes
to vendors and hosting providers or any of
those other things that you might want.
We are independent of of infrastructure, so to
speak. We we pretty much work play well
with any of your existing stack.
And overall, from a component perspective, we have
a few different components, but three of them
primarily that we focus on.
Starting off with the open source API gateway,
which is what we are gonna be primarily
focusing on today.
And this is essentially the brains of the
operation. This is where all the and computation
primarily occurs when it comes to API management.
And that's coupled with our proprietary
dashboard,
which effectively provides a a graphic user interface
to interact with some of the capabilities that
we have in place.
And then we have a developer portal, which
is sort of like a lightweight
content management system in a in a sense,
which which enables you to catalog slash publish
the APIs that you've sort of managed through
Tyk or have developed as well.
So that those are the three main components.
There are a couple more that I'll touch
upon in in a little bit, but that's
sort of what the extent of our platform
is.
And I I said, we are light on
infrastructure,
and we are very, very extendable. So it's
very easy to extend the capabilities as well.
So things that you know, we we've got
a few capabilities coming out of the box.
But if that is not your liking, you
can very easily create your own plugins
in a few different languages, including,
well, JavaScript, Node. Js,
Python, and Go. Go is the language that
Tyk has been built on to keep things
really, really lightweight and and efficient.
But if you if you do choose to
do so, if you do choose to extend
the capabilities, you can do so in other
languages as well.
Then the third point is around flexibility where
we are capable of handling different API styles.
And by this, I mean, essentially, not just
REST endpoints or REST based API API
endpoints, which is typical for for most API
management platforms.
But we can also handle your more legacy
systems like like SOAP or
the more well, for the lack of better
word, the the newer evolution
of APIs, which is around GraphQL.
By no means a replacement of REST, but
it is a newer sort of technology, although
it's been around for a while. But we
are capable of handling all of these different
API styles. So regardless of what you have
as part of your stack, as part of
your API product,
you can use Tyk to to manage that,
secure it, and perhaps extend the capabilities as
well.
We have another component which we will be
showcasing towards the end of the session today,
which is called the universal data graph, which
enables you to actually stitch together data
from different data sources,
which means
if you do have REST endpoints, perhaps even
SOAP endpoints or GraphQL endpoints,
you can effectively combine all of those different
data sources, data from those different data sources,
and create a unified
schema out of it, a GraphQL schema, and
expose it out in that sense, in that
fashion. And we'll show you how you can
do that. Obviously, this this provides a big
benefit when it comes to, you know, if
you're looking to explore GraphQL or you're looking
to bring together data from different data sources,
you can do that in a low code
or, in this case, no code manner as
well. So we'll be showcasing this without having
to write any code whatsoever. No resolve was
required. No middleware required to do this.
And then finally, we fit really well with
your existing stack, sort of goes to that
platform agnostic view of our existence
where
if you have your existing
stack, if you have your existing products,
we try our best to essentially fit in
as seamlessly possible as seamlessly as possible with
that. So whether you're on Kubernetes, which is
you've got the Tyk operator, enables you to
manage that really, really easily, and we'll be
showcasing that as well. If
you are
looking at API governance, for instance, we have
open policy agent that will enable you to
do that in a very powerful way.
Or if you have if you want if
you already have identity providers that act as
authorization
servers within your organization, then we can really
easily integrate with that using the dynamic client
registration. Out of the box, we have abilities
to
integrate with Okta, Glue,
Keycloak,
but we are gonna be looking at further
additions to that as well. So we're pretty,
pretty flexible in that sense to do that.
K.
Just a little bit about the life cycle
management. Just for those who are new to
how the API life cycle sort of works,
especially around the API management journey of things,
there are usually two stakeholders. We look at
API providers, people who are creating the APIs
and making it available for consumption,
and the API consumers
who are effectively consuming
the API endpoints to build out their own
product.
So on the side of the API providers,
you effectively create, test, secure, and manage
your APIs on the side of the consumers.
You are looking to discover and find out
what what the available APIs are to you
and how you would go about using it,
develop products on top of those, consume it,
and then, of course, monitor and optimize depending
on how the consumption is happening on your
end.
So that's sort of a basic journey into
the API lifecycle management,
followed by what Tyk does in this space.
So from the API provider perspective, things like
access control,
your rate limiting, which is essentially
the limitations or limitations that you might want
to put in terms of how many requests
that you might want to
make available over a period of time. This
could be part of your API monetization strategy
or your load management strategy,
but that's available to you.
We've got an API designer that that provides
you a bit bit more of a user
interface to work with to to create or
manage your APIs,
analytics,
versioning, authorization, authentication from a security perspective.
From the API consumers perspective, we've got our
documentation,
which is, I think I mentioned around the
developer portal, which sort of handles the API
consumption aspect of things.
You can catalog your APIs and consume the
APIs that are available to you. You can
discover whatever is available to you and how
to make use of that through documentation.
So just as a as a simple sort
of starting point, and we'll obviously see some
of these in action shortly.
It's a little bit about the components that
we've got. This is not entirely exhaustive at
the moment, but these are sort of the
primary components
with the API gateway, which is our open
source component right at the center of it
all
with
the ways to interact with the gateway being
the dashboard, being the more graphic user interface
aspect of things. This is this is part
of the enterprise edition, not the open source
edition. As part of your open source edition,
you would have the command line interface coupled
with Tyk operator, especially if you're working with
the in the Kubernetes world
like we're gonna be doing today.
But these would be the ways to interact
with the gateway and the capabilities of the
gateway.
On the other end, we have the developer
portal, which is again the way to publish
or catalog your APIs.
And then you have the Tyk pump, which
is a component that enables you to. It's
essentially the observability
layer for,
the the API management platform before Tyk.
I don't I don't believe we're gonna be
going too deep into this today, but this
is essentially the component that enables you to
look at monitoring and logging and analytics and
all of those different things around observability.
It basically allows us to send any any
analytics data that's been generated as your gateway
handles traffic.
The pump allows you to send that
analytics data out to any third party
observability platform.
So maybe you're using Splunk or Prometheus or
an ELK Stack.
That's what it's there for, as well as
actually sending
analytics data into
our own platform if you wanted to use
the analytics that built that's built in with
the Tyk Enterprise edition.
Does this support in FluxDB? Because we know
that's the best type for your database.
I actually would have to check that, but
ring us a bell.
It does. I see it on the documentation
yesterday.
Yeah. Got it. Yeah.
Got that. We got that. Yeah. Yeah. I'm
a big fan of influx. Anyway, sorry.
No worries. No worries. Alright. Yeah. I think
I think I think, like like Andy mentioned,
I think it's very easy to plug into
plug in this data into external systems. Of
course, pump is what powers our internal analytics
platform and monitoring platform as well within Tyk
as part of our dashboard as well as
the gateway. But like you mentioned, you can
plug into external systems as well, which could
include even your BI tools potentially as well.
So
depending on what you choose to make use
of.
Yeah. It's an it's an open source component.
So if you did want to send Yeah.
Analytics data out to some observability or monitoring
platform that we don't currently spot,
you can write a a pump for it.
Yep. So I I think this one sort
of gives you that that idea as well.
So I think this is sort of a
little bit of a view of the open
source landscape within a within Tyk.
So I think the gateway itself looks at
things like security,
versioning, and body transforms, traffic control,
monitoring. And part of that monitoring extension, we
look at the Tyk pump. And like you
said, we've got we've got support for
Influx, Datadog, Elasticsearch,
Kafka as well as Splunk, Prometheus, Mosif.
We are we are soon gonna be adding
a couple more to it as well. But
it's it's really, really simple to extend this
capability. And if you if you do have
an observability platform that you have, it's very
easy to hook hook on to Tykbomb to
to gather that information.
So that's pretty much the Tykbomb we've got
at the moment. There is the identity broker
as well, which sort of connects to external
or custom identity providers.
So if you're looking at OAuth and third
party authorization
through any of these available systems, then you
can do that using the identity broker as
well.
And then finally, we've got our Tyk operator
for Kubernetes,
which is what we'll be demonstrating today,
coupled with the Tyk CLI,
which, again, this is this completes sort of
our open source API management offering at the
moment.
Just as an extension to this, of course,
we do have an enterprise edition edition for
Tyk as well where
some of these capabilities are primarily extended. The
base capability, the the open source gateway is
the same that powers both of our products.
So there is no
I would say there there are no two
separate products under the hood. You have the
API gateway, the same API gateway, open source
API gateway powering both of them. With the
enterprise edition, of course, a couple of things
just become a little bit easier in that
sense to to manage because you have a
nicer interface to sort of work with. A
couple of
things that are associated with the dashboard, for
instance,
like the open policy agent at the moment
and with the developer portal, like the the
dynamic client registration capability, for instance, Those are
a bit more of an enterprise
capability as it stands today.
And, of course, the bigger one that we
we are gonna be showcasing towards the end
is the universal data graph where
you really can
design
sort of your own
GraphQL schema based on existing infrastructure.
And that further enables you to publish those
those
schema stitched or sort of stitched data
from different sources as a GraphQL endpoint.
So I think that's sort of something that
is is better shown off towards the end,
but that is part of our enterprise edition
here as well. And further to that, we
have a multi data center bridge, MDCB offering,
which is
especially useful when you're looking to manage
Tyk across different multiple data centers,
whether that is within a particular region or
different data centers in the same region or
across multiple regions, you can handle that. You
can essentially install
or deploy local
instances of the gateway to provide all of
the processing power
at at a local level.
But you can manage all of that through
a centralized sort of control plane instead of
having to manage each of the different
gateways individually.
So essentially,
deploy locally and manage globally. That's sort of
the way to go with data center. Of
course, I've I've oversimplified that a little bit
because we can obviously go much deeper into
the data center
bridge. But I think as an introduction, I
think that sort of does hopefully a good
job. And from a from a offering as
well as the multi geo thing that the
MDCV is is also useful.
I think it's more with the
bigger clients that we work with where you
find the different business units or teams within
an organization. They want their own runtime environment.
They want their own gateway, but they want
everything to be managed through this central control
plane. So it also plays into that space.
Yep. Exactly.
And then finally, we've got our Tyk cloud
offering, which is sort of our our SaaS
offering in this case,
which is for you to get up and
running really quickly without having to think about
managing your infrastructure.
It is it is sort of part SaaS,
part orchestration because you can choose where you
want to deploy
your control plane as well as your
local instances of the of the local gateway,
the edge gateways as we call them.
And you can beyond just having a fully
managed solution with Tyk, you can also extend
that further as a hybrid solution where you
can use the Tyk control plane
on the cloud and connect
your local installations of
the local gateway,
which you can host in your own
private cloud if you do choose to do
so
or in your own infrastructure.
So that's sort of the the hybrid aspect
of this that comes along with the Tykloud.
I think with this, I think we'll dive
into today's sort of
today's demonstration,
and I'm gonna pass this on to Andy
to give you a little bit of more
into what the actual architecture of Tyk looks
like. And then right after this, we will
be heading on to the hands on session.
So over to you, Andy.
Yeah. Sure. So this this this architecture
schema that we're looking at actually covers both
the open source components and
some of the license component as well. So
it's a it's it's kind of a a
a simple
licensed architecture.
For what we're gonna be focusing on today
for the open source piece, that's essentially
a gateway that sits between
your
API clients
and
your upstream
services that are hosted on some API server.
And the gateway has one dependency,
which is Redis,
and we use that
to store
session tokens. So it might be API keys,
for example.
We also
temporarily store
analytics data in Redis before TykE pump picks
up that analytics data and sends it off,
where it needs to go. So,
in terms of,
an open source installation, it's pretty simple. It's
a gateway, and it's Redis and optionally pump.
Okay.
I think I'm gonna stop sharing the screen
now. I
do wonder if there are any questions that
might have already come up at this moment.
Otherwise, we can head on over to the
next segment.
Nothing
from the audience yet, but I'm sure they'll
be in with their questions soon.
I guess something that pops into my head
through that is, like, what what doesn't Tyk
do? Like, that was a healthy list of
features. Right? Like,
I mean, I guess that shows the maturity.
Like, I didn't realize Tyk was seven years
old at this point in time. So it's
been developed for a while. I didn't realize
the company had a hundred employees. I mean,
that's a sizable you know, that's no venture
beyond startup. Right? Like, Tyk must be
kicking a lot of ass. I imagine a
lot of people are using this and I'm
just really disappointed that I personally hadn't heard
about it until recently because it seems to
solve so many problems
that I have in API management and a
cloud native environment with microservices
with delegated authorization.
All all all these things
are super painful, and all this time Tyk
has been sitting there in open source land
and
gutted that I just missed it all this
time.
Yeah. We we sometimes call it batteries included,
so it's it's it's cloud native. It's pretty
lightweight.
It fits in nicely with
modern requirements around automation and CICD
and all of that. But it it remains
lightweight while still providing a ton of capability.
Awesome.
Well, I think we just dive straight in
and we start playing with it, and let's
see what we can do with Tyk. So
Let's do it. Let's pull up my screen
share.
I have the homepage here. For anyone who
wants to check it out at their own
time, you can visit tyk.io.
I also have access to the getting started
gate available via the documentation.
And I have one Kubernetes cluster ready for
us to start deploying too. But we haven't
done anything upfront other than provision a Kubernetes
cluster and everything else we will do as
we work through this.
So we do have a question if you
want to tackle that from Russell, which has
just slid in there before we started our
hands on component. So Russell asks,
why Redis when etcd seems to be the
default choice for key value storage and the
cloud native ecosystem?
I
mean, it was an an architecture choice going
back
four, five years. I don't know if
there is under consideration
something like etcd
to
to bring in in the future, but I
think Redis has served us pretty well
over the years so far.
Yeah. Redis is a great database.
Really, really fast. Written in c works really
well. Guess the
I mean, I'm I'm just gonna put words
in your mouth. I don't work for Tyk
or not even know why these decisions were
made.
But I would sometimes reach for Redis because
the operational complexity versus STDs are lot simpler.
And I wonder if maybe that was a
decision there. So good question, Russell. Hopefully, that
gives you some answers.
Okay.
So getting started guide. Now are we going
to run through
We're gonna do an install. So Yeah.
Let's try and run through this menu structure.
So install open source,
and then
for all of these different
flavors of installation, be it self managed license
or open source, there's there's all there's a
number of different options. So I think somewhere
either at the bottom of this page or
in the menu on the left,
we should be able to find our way
to
if you just scroll down the page,
then there's an OSS section in there.
And then I think probably from the left
hand navigation
on this page, you'll see open source installation.
Again, bunch of options because we can be
installed on bare metal or virtual machines or
Docker or Kubernetes. Let's go for a Kubernetes
install.
You read that name. Yeah.
I was hoping you were gonna go along
with this, then TykOSS
Helm chart is
how we shall do this.
Okay. So we do have a couple of
options here. Right? We can use the Helm
charts. We can deploy directly with manifest and
there as the operator. So are we going
with Helm now and we'll look at the
operator later? Is that the plan? Yeah. So
how it works is
for installation,
customers, most people we work with, they're gonna
use the Helm charts to actually
deploy Tyk, and then they would use the
operator
to actually publish API definitions and
actually, yeah, publish their runtime resource.
But the the the the the gateway itself
will install with Helm.
Cool. We have a cataculta scenario. Those are
all the latest. I think this just popped
up yesterday. So the
the the docs are, yeah, on under change
at the moment.
So I think if we wanna work in
your own terminal, in your own Yeah. This
is directly just This is this is something
that we've sort of we are sort of
introducing so that people can have a hands
on component really, really quickly early on if
they want to try it out without having
to set things up for themselves.
So, hopefully, that is gonna extend out to
other aspects of the of the documentation as
well. I think we've we've done a pretty
decent job getting it up and running so
far. So,
hopefully, next time we speak, we'll have a
even more complete
part of this. Nice. Well, I have added
the repository via Helm. I have run Helm
repo update. I have created the Tyk namespace.
And now we have to install Redis first.
Yep.
And this we we within our Helm charts,
we ship with a
a simple Redis,
which is really there just for,
I would say, evaluation,
just getting to know Tyk. There are official
Vietnamese charts as well that you'd be more
likely to use in a a real environment.
Okay.
So
I ran that. It looks like a Redis
was happy. I was oh, no. That's What's
that process?
Okay. There's our Redis inside. I was a
bit worried we weren't gonna get a happy
Redis because I don't remember if my cluster
has a CSI driver deployed,
but it looks like it's okay. So phew.
Phew. Yep.
And now we can install
take I'm assuming CEO's community edition.
That's right. Actually,
I was just gonna say before you do
that,
I think there's a little bit of configuration
to do.
So we might have to uninstall
that.
It's actually further down the page. So
it breaks all this down and there's a
step there where we actually there's some configuration
values. We should at least have a look
at that values dot YAML file. Yeah. Of
course. So I I I would uninstall what
you just installed and then
Okay. May maybe it just works, but
so Yeah. I I can remove it. It
it that's not a big deal. So we
can do a helm l s
at minus and take l s
and delete.
I mean, maybe if we could just leave
it, we could try it.
That's okay. Let's let's not introduce opportunity for
things to go wrong just because I'm too
quick to push the return key.
So we do have our values
dot YAML here.
So Assuming I should change this.
I think for now you can leave it.
It's up to you. Normally, you would, but,
yeah, we're gonna need whatever you put in
here, we're gonna need at some point.
And then
we have a
some options here that tells Tyk how it
needs to connect to Redis. So
there's two options. There's
that first part there, which is what we
should use,
that's, I I believe,
the Redis service that you should have running
now on port 6379.
Yeah. It seems this is the default, so
we should be okay just to leave that.
Yeah. Then
for what we're gonna do today, that's it.
We're not using Mongo. We're not using pump.
So
k. And then there's some gateway configuration around
as a daemon set, supposedly on node port,
cluster IP,
and then there's the pump config. Okay.
Yeah.
I'm just gonna I think there are other
than that as is should be okay. Just
running. We'll find out. We'll see.
So now if we take a look at
our namespace,
we have our three gateways running. That's because
it's a daemon set and I have a
I think a three node cluster.
Okay.
Interesting.
Right.
Is that what you expected?
I've never tried it on anything beyond a
a a one node cluster myself. So
yeah.
And that that that in terms of installation,
that's it. So we should have a gateway
there. So you should be able to
I would normally
port forward my my service so I can
hit my gateway from local host.
So I don't know if we can just
use one of those gateways.
And then 808443.
Perfect.
Yeah. And then if you've got another window,
there's a little health check we can try.
Yep. What's the path?
Slash hello.
Let me zoom in on that.
Oh, too much. Woah. It's okay to me.
There we go. So we got a status
pass. We get the version. I get a
little bit of description, and we get some
information about the Redis connection. So to you,
that looks like we have a healthy Tyk
gateway running.
To me, that looks pretty good. Yeah. Perfect.
There you go. Painless. Absolutely painless.
So So if we go back to the
docs now and on the left hand nav
under getting started,
And we can start with create an API.
And there's
three tabs there. Yep. Perfect. So open source
is the way we're gonna go.
So with with the open source gateway, there's
there's actually there's three ways to configure an
API.
So
the first way is to actually configure
an API definition,
which is just that it's it's it's a
JSON file. You would configure that on the
file system.
Option number two is to configure an API
via the gateway's
REST API,
and I I think that's what we'll do
next. And then
once we've been through that, we'll have a
look at how you would do this with
the operator as well.
Okay. So what you're saying there is to
get to find an API with the TykEatway,
we're gonna author something locally,
have the rest API of the gateway is
gonna do it. But at the same time,
or at least afterwards, we can use the
operator, which will allow us to use a
custom resource to apply the same thing. That's
right. So the operator essentially provides a number
of custom resource definitions that basically allow you
to
work with Tyk in the same way that
you would
any other kind of Kubernetes object or or
or primitive,
and it allows you to do this in
a kind of GitOps style
declarative
API management.
But if we if we start with step
two there, and so we've got a sample
API in the docs that we can use
just to
just to start things off, at the top
of that curl command, there is
an authorization header.
The value for that authorization
header should be your secret that was in
your
values dot YAML file. I can't remember if
we left it as changing it. I did
also notice as well, these docs have just
they've just been they've been through a bit
of a refresh, and it looks like something's
gone amiss. So at the bottom of that
kill command,
you'll notice there's
a missing
closing quote for the payload.
And we're also missing the
URL support and the path to the API
endpoint. So I can I can take you
through all of that? That has actually I've
I've put a PR and I'm just waiting
for that to be merged.
Alright. Okay. So let's go with create an
API.
We're dropping our curl.
I'll call host 88. Pilot's trying to get
Too fancy there.
Alright. The path is?
Slash type
slash
APIs.
Oh, the Copilot knows.
See?
I don't know if you've played with Copilot
yet on Versus Code, but it can read
my mind. It is ridiculous. Wow.
And I think that closing quote should be
a single quote. Yeah. Well, yeah. There's doubles
and syncs. Yeah. You're right. There we go.
If the syntax highlighting doesn't work, you've messed
up. That's my rule. Okay.
And then, yeah, change the secret, the authorization
header to whatever was in the file. I
think we left it as default.
Yep.
I'll just make this a a real script.
So that should be able to run
now. So this is going to
authorize against the Tyk Gateway,
sending a post request. The payload this is
how we describe an API then. So we
have to give it This is how we
yeah. In in the nonoperator
world,
this is how we
describe
an API. There's actually there's a hell of
a lot more that you could put in
here that we're kind of doing
bare minimum
hello world type at the moment. So just
the
fields that we need to publish this API.
That's essentially it's gonna be as simple as
it can get on Tyk. It's
gonna publish an API that should be keyless,
so we won't need
any kind of API key or other type
of token to be able to hit this,
and it's gonna proxy to this
request response service out on the Internet. Yeah.
Nice. HTTP, Ben. I like that. Yeah. It's
yeah.
Okay. Let's create our
API. So I'm gonna need to keep my
port forward running. So let's just Yep. Put
this.
And I should be able to just run
or create an API.
Did that work?
No.
Getting connection reset back here. Let me recreate
the port forward.
Oh, hang on a minute. Sorry. Go to
port forward again.
If you bring up
yeah. This port forward eighty eighty to four
four three, isn't it?
Yeah. What did I get here? Local host
a is it HTTPS or HTTP?
HTTP.
Sorry. That's it.
That's better. There we go. Yeah. You can
I mean, if you want to enable TLS,
there's options in there to do that?
But yeah. Does it have native
ACME slash let's encrypt support, or would that
be something I use cert manager for?
You use cert manager for that. Alright. Okay.
I think we as part of the operator
installation,
there's a step in there to actually
install cert manager.
You can actually build use operator to
operate this gateway that's running in your Kubernetes
cluster, you can also I'm not sure if
we mentioned, you can also use it to
publish APIs and control
non Kubernetes gateways as well. You could even
point it at a
a Tyk installation
in Tyk Cloud, a SaaS service.
So the operator itself
is dependent on Kubernetes,
but you don't have to use it to
manage
Kubernetes environments.
Okay. Cool.
Now if I'm following a lot blah blah
blah. If I'm following along correctly,
I I feel like I should be able
to run local host local host
hello world, and that would be proxied onto
the API, or is there something to the
path I need to augment it with in
order for that to work?
So you would you might need a closing
slash, and it's sometimes useful also to use.
There's a bunch of methods on HTTP, bin,
one of which I normally use is
a slash get operation.
But, yeah, try and try try and just
hit hello world.
Not quite.
So let's go through this. I wanna make
sure I understand this definition correctly.
Yeah. So we've added something to the tech
gateway that says if we ever request hello
dash world slash, the the prop the request
will be proxied through to the HTTP band
service that you have publicly available here.
Although it does this trip lesson path. I'm
not sure
what's happening there.
Oh, yes. Because when you pass it on
to the following service, it takes that path
off. Right? So it would just be slash
on the remote service. Okay.
And I don't think much of this is
particularly important for right now. That is except
for the keyless and off, we're just saying
that there's no authorization on the remote API.
Is there anything that you want to highlight
here? Or is it
am I correct to say that it's not
that important right now?
Andy, did we lose you? Yeah. I think
his Internet's gone.
It's
alright. Yeah. So
I kind of expected this to work.
Let's let's let's try try that a little
bit differently. Maybe just I think maybe we
don't need that x get for now. Let's
if we were to get rid of that,
just make the curl request. Is that
just not finding the way okay.
Yeah.
I mean, we did create the API, didn't
we?
Yeah.
We got 200 okay key hello world status
action added.
We should follow the documentation instead of me
making it up. Maybe that's a good idea.
So we we did see this. We're happy
with that.
Mhmm. Oh, so there's an API's invite to
pull them up. All you have to do
think yeah. That I think is the authorization.
Yeah. So we have to tell it to
reload or restart the pods. So let's try
the reload command then. So
let me fix it off. So
this is change me. Change This
is HTTP
local host,
and I am forwarding on 8,080,
and we're just passing a reload.
And that looks okay. So I think now
You need to you do need to hot
reload the the gateway, I think. So I
think that's that's why it's not picking up
the API otherwise. Yeah. I think that's what
we're missing. So I think it worked now.
Yeah. Yep. That's what was missing. Perfect. Yep.
So I I think if you do if
you run the same with the get at
the end of that,
so if you curl that with slash get,
yeah, I think you should get a little
bit nicer.
Yeah. I think you get this one, which
is a bit more easier to read rather
than a, you know, HTML sort of thing
coming through. Yeah. Definitely. Yeah. That's all. Yeah.
Okay. I think we've got Andy back in.
It was hard to lock it, didn't it?
Had to happen. We did talk about it
right at the beginning. It just had to
happen.
But we managed came back pretty quickly. But,
yeah, then I I had trouble getting back
in the session. But, anyway, I'm back here.
So yeah. Sorry about that. We're we're smashing
it. We're we're we're we're reading the documentation.
We we we
got through it. It was I think we
needed to hot reload the gateway. So I
think we just did that, and it seemed
to be working at the moment. So that's
not a problem. Will be the next step.
Yeah. Cool. Okay.
Okay. So we did the reload. I can
now proxy a request to the issue to
prevent instance,
and that's working
quite nicely.
Lovely.
Okay.
Right. So we've we've created an API using
the REST API.
We've we've hot reloaded.
There's other options in here to create a
file based, but I would suggest we move
on to actually
the next step in the tutorial. So I
think that will be access and API.
Oh, you might have asked a couple of
questions. We also have one in the chat.
So Yeah. Sure. Why is the hot reloaded
into
Say again. Sorry. I was just gonna ask
one one one final thing, one one thing.
Andy, do we need to hit any other
specific endpoint to for the hot reload to
take effect?
Something around the slash API slash reload or
something on those lines slash Tyk slash reload,
or are we good at the moment since
we are getting a response? Is there anything
else that we need to do to make
sure it's it's all okay? If you hit
that if you sent a request to that
slash tyk slash reload,
you're good.
We did And by virtue of the fact
that you were able to actually send request
and get a 200 response
suggests that it has hot reloaded.
So why is the hot reload not automatic
when I create new p i's APIs? Like,
why do I need
to manually do that?
In the enterprise edition, this is one of
I'm not sure it's a benefit, but that's
certainly something that happens. So when you in
the enterprise edition, you publish in the dashboard,
and then, basically, there's a a pub sub
channel between the dashboard and the gateways, and
they hot reload automatically.
In the gateways, why that is not built
in by default? I honestly I don't know.
But
Okay.
So
oh, yeah. We got a a question from
Russell
who is asking, so what logging does take
pervade?
Does the log acts like whenever I
is there an auto log for when I
create or delete or edit APIs? Is there
a logging when I access APIs? Like, what
kind of stuff does it emit?
There's
so there's a number of things. So as
as you send requests to the API,
analytics
logs are generated,
and that's where this component that we mentioned
in Buddha's intro,
we have this component called Tykbump pump, which
essentially allows you to take those
analytics logs, which could that could actually be
full payload information or it could just be
metadata
and forward those analytics logs
off to a third party analytics
or monitoring system.
There are also
audit logs that
that may be an enterprise thing I'd have
to check, but in some part of the
stack, there are also audit logs that show
you when an administrator has
published a new API definition, for example, or
maybe they've they've created a key, they've done
something
that we generated an audit event for.
Alright. Perfect. Thank you very much.
Okay. So what do wanna do next then,
Andy? What was it you said there?
So I think the next step, if we
just scroll up,
there's
a next the next step in the tutorial
is to access an API.
We'll have a quick look at that, and
we're we're gonna have to change something to
do this.
So this is
right now, we've got an API that was
we set it as keyless.
And so what we're gonna do instead now
is we're actually
let's first of all,
we'll publish a new API, and I'll I'll
I'll take you through what config
you need to provide for that. And then
we'll
generate an API key that we'll then use
at runtime to access
that secured API.
Did that make sense? It does. Yeah.
So I think if you go back to
the the definition that you had previously
and let's just create another version of this
and, yeah,
maybe call it hello world
two or something
Or whatever you want.
Create an API two. Why not?
Come on, computer. You can do this.
Okay. There we go. I mean, we could
just update that. We could
send a put request and update the existing
thing. But if we just create a new
one
so we'll give it a new name,
change the slug, change the ID.
Instead of use keyless,
if we change that to be
you could do that or you could just
simply
not have that configuration item and instead use
we'll put in there in its place,
use
stand use underscore
standard
underscore
auth.
Oh, look at that.
Oh, tried to and now it's no one
no other things I want.
Swagger.
I'm
sure it's off, but Yeah. Yeah.
And we'll set that to true.
Is that it? Yeah.
We've got the off header name.
Yeah. And then I think just change the
listen path that's
in there somewhere.
Oh, hello world tour.
Yeah.
Okay.
Done.
Cool. What's
really, the main difference here is we have
removed to use keyless, and instead we're using
standard off. So what what does that mean?
So it means to access this API night,
now you need to provide a
a bearer token
that's been
either
generated
by Tyk or imported in as a custom
API key into Tyk.
Okay.
And so, yeah, that that's the next part
of the tutorial. You you you publish an
API that's secured and then we generate an
API key. And so
if we
Copy this.
Take this and then we'll have a look
at it and we'll we'll chain we'll change
the API that it's trying to access. In
fact, I think it's just templated, so it
should be fine.
Okay. So this is create a key.
That should be change me.
Yeah.
Okay. So this is interesting.
Right? So when we create a take key,
we can actually set
quarters and rate limits that allow you to
access the That is really, really cool.
Yeah.
There is actually another way to do this,
which it's it's not part of the getting
started guide. So you can do all of
these things directly on a key, that's, I
suggest, that's what we carry on doing.
But there is also
another object in Tyk called a security policy,
and a security policy,
basically allows you to kind of centralize the
control of these keys such that imagine you've
got hundreds or thousands of these keys that
are set with certain rate limits and quotas
on day one.
If you wanted to go in and you
wanted to
update all of those rate limits rather than
updating all of the keys,
If you use policies instead, you can just
update the policy, which when you create a
key, you template on values from the policy.
So you see much the same configuration. You
see rate limits, API access control lists, all
of the same stuff. When you create a
key from a policy,
if you were to update that key, any
related
sorry. If you were to update that policy,
any related key would also get updated.
Okay.
So there are two things in my head.
I'll start with the the question first, and
then I'll add on the the weird thing
that I wanna break on this key. So
I I do a lot of automation with
the YouTube API, and I have very strict
quotas from Google on that YouTube API. Is
that something I would try to replicate or
emulate using a key intake? Or would I
just rely on YouTube returning
their quota saying I'm over? Like,
if you were doing that yourself, how would
you make that work? So just repeat that
again. So, yeah. Whenever I created the YouTube
API, I got a quota of, like,
a thousand requests per day. Now would I
then try and replicate that quota with a
take key so that I never really quite
hit the YouTube one, or would I just
rely on the YouTube one, throw in the
error anyway, and handle it externally?
So, typically, you offload
that kind of thing
onto Tyk.
So, yeah, quite often, we work with customers
that have
historically,
they've implement their own kind implemented their own
rate limiting or quota
quota system.
Generally, you just when you introduce a gateway
into the infrastructure,
usually, you would leave that type of thing
to be performed by the gateway.
If if you if if your if your
API if you're saying that YouTube YouTube's already
providing it, I would still
do it in Tyk.
Apart from anything else, if you use a
a Tyk API key, as requests come in,
you're gonna get analytics in Tyk via the
pump to understand
who's using what and when and how much.
We would tie
the analytics to the key.
We also have
we didn't configure it, but we've got rate
limits on a key are fairly typical.
We also allow you to configure rate limits
on an API definition. It's actually it's a
different use case at that point. That's more
about
protection.
So if you know your infrastructure can only
handle
so many requests per second, then it makes
sense to set a rate limit on the
API definition
rather than
setting rate limits per consumer.
Yeah. That makes a lot of sense. Thank
you for that. We have a a couple
of questions in the chat. So Bella is
asking, is it possible to set a client
max rate limit?
I'm not sure I understand that. I don't
know if that'll make sense for you.
So a max rate limit per client. Like
a rate
I mean, the rate limit we set is
the the
maximum. So if you were to
update that rate limit to be five requests
per minute
or or or second, that's the maximum amount
that they can send.
Okay. And one for the last question. Sorry.
I I think the question might be around,
if there is a restriction on the number
clients themselves rather than the request. I think
we go based on request. So regardless of
I'm assuming is it is it specific for
those requests to come from specific clients? I
would assume not. I think it's dependent on
the number of requests coming in.
So you set a rate limit per client.
That's what we're doing here. The rate limit
is tied to the key that we're creating.
There is also that other rate limit. So
we could have set a rate limit on
an API.
Say that rate limit was a hundred requests
per second, and then you start issuing keys
that have rate limits.
The rate limit on the API definition is
the one that rules all. So regardless of
where the requests are coming from,
if you hit that rate limit, you're gonna
start getting
four two nines or whatever it's gonna be.
Okay. Thank you. Okay. So we got one
more question from Russell who's asking
if those quotas could be part of a
group or company level rather than a key.
So could I set,
like, my say that you know, we see
org ID in here. Like, say I want
to split my team into multiple organizations. Can
the quotas be applied to that org ID?
I think there might be some kind of
organization quota. We might have to dip dip
into the docs there to check it. Yeah.
I guess you could always generate a key
per group or team with that. You
could have a key shared by members of
a team or group, I guess. Yeah. I'm
wondering whether there is actually. There's something at
the back of my mind that we've got
some kind of organization
quota as well, but I can't remember what
that looks like.
We can have a quick look in the
docs. I could have dreamed that.
Alright. Well
okay. So let's
can we change this
quota to be one request per minute just
so that we can, you know, contrive a
situation where we get we get we have
the quota.
You can you can generate another key.
So
So would that just be allowance one,
rate one?
I think the per is that's per
I think that's second. I'm just gonna bring
up the docs myself and just check this.
I think I think per is is per
second, I think. So I think if you
that's that's one of the best I can't
hear you very well, Budder. Sorry?
I can't hear you very well. I don't
know if that's just me or
Is it is it okay now? Are you
Oh, yeah. Budder, your audio has dropped.
What about now? Any changes? Anything? No. It's
still very, very, very quiet.
Well, I get you guys continue for the
time. Yes. Whatever you did there fixed it.
Okay.
Okay. Fine.
No. I was just saying, I think it
is per second. So it's a number of
requests you do per second. So I think
if you put it something like two requests
over ten seconds,
it'll be a little bit more visible,
I would imagine.
I think the allowance is actually deprecated. We'll
leave it in. But allowance and rate are
the same thing. And the rate is a
is that is that one so that that
the unit is second. So that's one request
per second you've got there.
So I I think one second might be
too small a time frame so for you
to check it out. So maybe if you
just do one rate per, I don't know,
three or five seconds perhaps over the Five
per 60
is something that's easy to check or or
one.
Yeah. Okay. Let's do two requests per one
minute. We can we can I can take
that fast? So and
this is gonna restrict access to our hello
world too, which is the API that we
have requiring
standard authentication.
So Yeah. Let's create our key then.
A
key.
That's a good point, actually. That key could
actually give you access to a bunch of
different APIs.
Or you
can actually go further than that, and you
can actually create keys that give access to
different paths within within different APIs.
So you might have some users that you
want to be able to access
all all all all paths within an API,
for example. There might be others that you
I don't know. You but you only wanna
be able you want to be able to
limit them to the
to the
get requests rather than be able to create
and update stuff.
Alright. Okay.
I'm get I'm getting cocky now. I think
I know what I'm doing. So
like, if we did this
oh, what did I get wrong?
In the header, you need authorization.
What? Oh, yeah. It's authorization
and then better space. Right? Like that. Yeah.
I mean, you don't actually need Barry. You
can it'll work if you include it, but
you don't need it.
Okay.
What have I broken?
I did call it hello world too, didn't
I? Oh, I've not created it yet. Bet
you.
Oh, I did.
Okay. I think I've done something wrong.
Let's so
the API did you hot reload?
No.
Okay. We've reloaded again, brother.
Access to this API has been disallowed. So
that means that my authentication failed?
It does. So either it means where it
thinks we're trying to hit an API that
this key hasn't been provided access to.
Did we definitely
API oh, the the case is different. So
Yeah.
Hello, world two. Hello, world two.
Is everything okay. I think the case
That might do it.
Oh, this one's got a small w in
it. I guess the slug doesn't really matter.
Right? It's the ID and the name.
The ID. Let's try it. Let's try recreating
that key.
Yeah.
And we get a new better token.
Do I need to reload for keys?
No. No? Okay. So we can
probably quicker to go this way.
Get
okay. That worked. So we've two per 60.
So this one should work again. And
we would expect now to potentially see
lefty.
There we go.
Oh, if I had to chat or tell
us we forgot to reload. Thanks, Moe.
Good to good to hear all paying attention.
Alright. I like that. I like being able
to define the keys, which APIs they can
access, build down all that rate limiting, etcetera,
into it.
It's a nice nice little feature.
Do you fancy having a crack at the
operator? Let's go for it. I'm feeling like
we can do this now. So
let's do
oh, is it getting started?
Install
open source.
Let's see if the operator's in the docs.
You might it might be as easy just
to go to the so the install instructions
for the operator are in the GitHub repo.
Yeah. I've got it here.
And there's a link there installing Tyk operator,
so let's do that.
We're just past the hour mark, but I
think we're good for time.
So all of the prereqs, I think we're
fine with.
It says cert manager must be installed.
Yeah. It's part of the instructions, so we'll
we'll we'll do that. That's included.
The operator so you can actually you can
point operator at both
an open source installation,
which is what we're gonna do, so we're
gonna point it at a gateway. If you're
running the enterprise edition of Tyk, then you
would point it at the dashboard
instead.
But for us, it's
a gateway.
So could you maybe just zoom in a
little bit? Just
perfect.
So we'll if we yeah. And you can
create a separate namespace for this, but equally,
if you wanted to run it in the
same name namespace as your gateway, that's fine
as well.
Just make sure that we update
any of the commands that we need to.
Okay. So let's just take
namespace.
Yeah.
Create a secret. And so the auth is
going to be our change me.
Correct.
And the org, I don't think we set
one. Is that just one? Think yeah. We
can use one. I think that's what was
actually set in those
definitions. To be honest, org is more an
enterprise thing.
It has more meaning because the the enterprise
product is the dashboard is multi tenant, an
organization equals a tenant, but we'll we'll set
that to one. This
should be
your
Kubernetes DNS for that type gateway
service. What's the mode?
If you go back to the dock, I
think it's
tight c or just c for yeah.
Okay. So we're putting on the same same
namespace, which means it should be able to
have it on just just take Time. I
guess we can
let's just expand that out
just in case. Was it just Tykall? Was
it Tykall?
I think if you have a look at
the service in
in Kubernetes, then it will be something like
type c headless.
Something something something.
Yep. You are correct.
Good catch. So let's set this to
first dot take dot s v c dot
cluster dot org. Okay. Let's do this.
We have our secret,
and then the next step is to
So there's
yeah. There's options here for the operator to
be able to just watch all namespaces or
if you're only interested in
watching certain namespaces, you can do that.
We can skip through some of this. The
next install instruction is, I think, will be
to install cert manager. So we can just
copy that.
Then Just a quick one to just just
point out.
You sort of I'm I'm hoping I'm audible
now.
When you when you created that service, I
think instead of using Tyk, I think it's
tk y as opposed to t yk. I
don't know if it is intentional or not.
If you go back to
the command line,
the service that you've got there.
Oh, there's a tky.svc.+dr.
Good spot.
Yeah. That's the headless.tky
instead of tyk. Yeah.
Yeah. We we might need to correct that.
Alright.
Secret.
It's gonna fail, so I'm gonna have to
delete it.
The secret.
Good catch.
So we've got cert manager.
We've got our secret.
Now we could deploy the CIDs.
Yep.
So it wants me to have this code
locally. Right?
No.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah. Sorry.
And the CRDs can just be applied
from there.
I guess that's not gonna be take operator
helm CRDs.
And lastly,
we can
install our helm chart, which is just gonna
give us a secret for configuration.
Yeah. We'll change that namespace as well.
Yep.
Just a second. Just go back to the
docs.
Yeah. That looks correct.
Okay.
Sorry about haven't finished.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
Describe.
Oh, it's a crash lit back off.
Hopefully, that's it just
getting healthy.
It could be, but it's been a while.
I'd be a little bit suspicious.
That's a fun message.
Error registering call only.
Okay. It's cert manager.
I mean, this is a one twenty two
cluster.
It could just be cert manager.
And it's a a newer version. I think
we installed one zero three, which is a
little bit old.
Let's just go over the top of it
and see if that helps.
Yeah. It seems about It looks a little
better now. Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. So let's try
I will have to to set up grid.
I thought you could do dash dash name.
Oh no, it would be dash dash install,
but we don't even need that anyway. Cool.
So we have our three gateways only now.
We have our operator container crane. So let's
just pull in the image.
So we got a comment from Chandra.
It might just be an API version deprecation.
Yeah. I think we just updated the the
new assert manager.
A lot changed with one twenty two. A
lot of APIs disappeared. So Right.
So while that's coming up, why don't we
head back to the docs for Tyk operator,
and we'll just try and
we can either build one from scratch, but
given it's ten past three, it might make
sense to just go into the samples and
so if you go back to the root
of Tyk operator, there's a config folder.
Yep.
And within there, there should be a samples
directory.
And then down the bottom or somewhere in
the middle, in fact, there's a h t
t b bin dot yaml.
We could work with that.
We might need to change the name and
the ID, but
just scroll up a bit.
There's just like a basic keyless thing, the
equivalent of what we did when we first
created an API using the gateway REST API.
Yep.
Okay. So we can do
let's call it c r dot yaml. Let's
define the new API.
Let's change the name. Something else.
So I don't think we have on code.
It should be better. It's just called hello
world. So we should be Oh, you're right.
Yeah. We should be fine.
It's not okay. Yeah. Let's just go to
I'm confident.
Gonna work.
Assuming So hope hopefully, the
it's still creating. Okay.
Let's see.
It's waiting for
Cert manager. That's not a certificate.
Setup failed for volume. Cert.
Webhook
service cert not found. Is this? I think
what happened is when we did the upgrade,
we skipped one of the hooks that's probably
required to generate the cert. Install and do
it again.
Yeah.
Sorry, Fu. Same for you to leave.
We could just do that again.
Okay.
There we go. Yeah. So
just that broken install. I think we missed
a hook, but we appear to be alright
now.
Yeah. There we go. Two of two ready.
So we can apply our c r dot
yaml
And
Yeah. So you could do that. If you
do that, k get tyk APIs now and
just see if it's actually there's a thing
configured that the operator's aware of.
Type slash tyk slash a p I if
you wanted to hit the rest of it.
Oh, my key. And you do the key
as well. I'm making this difficult for myself
now. What was it? X take authorization?
Very good. There we go.
So that means I'm just gonna feel really
confident now. I I really wanna get to
business demo too. So we should be able
to have HTTP
bin get now.
Yep.
Oh, reload.
No.
It shouldn't need to reload.
I'm doing so kubectl
get
tyk APIs, all one word.
Enabled.
The path is correct.
We might actually have to look in the
operator logs.
Oh, k.
But,
I think perhaps we just we'll move on.
The
manager.
Yeah.
So it did reconcile.
So I was a bit quick to skip
looking at this APIs, but we should be
able to see all the APIs registered with
the gateway. Right? So
there's hello world.
Hello world two.
And
do we have
h to be pinned?
No.
Okay. I don't think it worked. Correct. I
think I think it might need to you
might need to apply the file. No? I
think
I thought we already did that. But
Yeah.
Because we can run take APIs, and we
can see it here. Yeah. Type APIs thinks
it's there, but for one reason, I don't
know why. But
And the manager does seem to think it's
reconciled.
Are are there any errors in there if
we look a bit further up? Or
Creating.
Completed.
And that is definitely the gateway on the
node that we've been testing with.
Because I know you,
when we installed the gateway,
I think you said you had a three
node setup.
So they're not clustered by default?
Yeah. So that's the the clustering in the
open source gateway, that's not there by default.
And so, actually, yeah, if you're using the
operator, that's something you've got to think about.
We do have customers that run TykEatWay in
a kind of
highly available fashion.
I believe they use
the,
file system method to configure their APIs. So
either they're using some kind of shared file
system or some other way to make sure
that their APIs are published on all the
gateways, but there isn't any clustering
by default as part of that open source
deployment type. You you get that by default
if you use the the licensed version.
Right.
Okay.
So why does it deploy as a daemon
set? That seems a bit
strange. It's I mean, it's it's it's so
that's a default setting to get started within
the health checks charts. You can go in
and you can change that to be a
a deployment.
Maybe
we should have done that, actually.
Alright. I'm sorry. We have seen a lot
of really cool stuff. So
really nice.
I I like the operator. I'm gonna have
to play around with this a little bit
more. But in the interest of time today,
and I don't wanna keep you here all
afternoon, why don't we allow Buddha to run
through some of the shiny UI stuff that
we have available as well? But you wanna
pop your screen up, and we can jump
over to that?
Yep.
Great. Okay.
So
before I get started, there are a couple
of installations that I have. One is purely
the Tyk cloud, which I'll show you. And
the other one is a local installation that
I have on my own system.
So you can do either one. I'm not
gonna go through the installation process again, which
might take a little bit of time, but
it pretty much follows a similar structure. Maybe
it's actually, it might even be a little
bit easier in terms of installation.
Follow the docs. You'll be able to get
up and running really, really quickly.
The only difference between the cloud versus the
the enterprise edition for installation is that when
you're starting off with a free trial on
the cloud, it you don't need a license
key. I think for the local installation,
you will need a license trial license key
as well for that. So that's pretty much
the only difference. Otherwise,
you can pretty much do the same things
as you can do local versus cloud. So
I'll just show you the interface of both
of them just so that you know a
bit, And then I'll go into the universal
data.
Okey dokey. So let me share
the screen.
Hopefully, I'm just gonna share.
Alright. There we go. So this is the
Tykloud.
So this is sort of the overview of
what we are providing here. So Tykloud is
a little bit different from basic SaaS because
it's more of a it's sort of a
combination of
a completely managed solution plus an orchestration solution
as well,
where you can
choose regions to deploy your control plane as
well as edge gateway.
The control plane, which is essentially your your
dashboard for for management of your APIs, essentially
is in the region in which you are
based out of. So you that's a singular
region that you would choose. For instance, I
have chosen Singapore
at the moment, so my control plane is
gonna be
deployed in in Singapore.
And then within the control plane, you have
options to actually add on further gateways, local
gateways or edge gateways as we call it.
So I already have a setup with a
control plane and
the edge gateway. If I go into this,
you'll see that I've got my manager dashboard
here and developer portal all set up, which
I can access through this URL. And underneath
this all, I've got the edge gateway,
which is gonna be my localized gateway for
the processing part of things.
To just give you a sense of the
dashboards,
So
here you go. You've got your
dashboard,
which is essentially
an overview at the moment of all the
API activities that is going on. This is
as an overview. And And then you can
go into the specifics of this, which I'll
go over
when I switch on to the the on
premises version. But you can see your APIs
that you might have created.
You can have your policies and keys, which
I'll touch upon shortly as well. So it's
it's kind of like the a user interface
for you to interact with
whatever is going on at the gateway level
or whatever capabilities that you want to
make available.
The only other thing is in terms of
deployments and things like that, it's it's pretty
straightforward to do this over here
if you do choose to deploy a new
edge gateway. So if you're man trying to
manage multiple local gateways, you essentially put in
a name, you add in a type,
and then fill in a a few information,
and it would be ready to go for
you. The the interesting part is also around
versions because we do have certain versions available
already. The latest version that we're working on
right now is three point two point one.
And
but you can add older versions as well
if you do want to do so.
Probably not recommended, but in case that is
something that you're looking at.
So in the interest of time, I'm gonna
switch over to my local installation, which is
gonna seem very familiar. So this is a
local installation at the moment.
This should look very familiar from a dashboard
perspective,
very similar to what we had here with
the Tyk cloud.
And
in here, we've got a few different capabilities.
And so what I'm gonna be doing today
is that I'm gonna be showing you how
you can
use
two REST endpoints
and construct
a GraphQL schema using that. And then once
we have the GraphQL schema, we'll add in
a little bit of security
policy on top of that as well. So
before the example that I'm gonna be using,
I'm gonna be using
this user information, which I've gotten from the
website, jasonplaceholdertykico.com.
I'm gonna be using users, and I'm gonna
be mapping this as as in the form
of a GraphQL schema.
So, hopefully, this is visible,
And I'm gonna head back onto my installation,
head on over to APIs.
I've got a bunch of these already, but
I'm gonna create a new one.
This
is gonna be a GraphQL API. I'm gonna
call it
test
user info.
I'm gonna be choosing the universal data graph,
and I'm gonna be composing a new GraphQL
service.
So with that, I'm gonna hit configure.
To begin with,
again, you've got all of these different options,
which we can go into the details of
it for now. I'm gonna skip that. The
one that I'm interested in to begin with
is this authentication mode towards the end. I'm
just gonna make this keyless to begin with
and save it.
Back on into the user info,
and I'm gonna start constructing my schema.
So by default, of course, we have mutation
and query queries in there. I'm not gonna
use mutations for now, so I'm just gonna
skip that.
And before I change my query, I'm gonna
add in a new type called
user.
It's gonna map my user object. I'm not
gonna map everything. So if you see this
object has a few different
fields or keys,
which is ID, name, username, email. I'm just
gonna pick out the ID name and email
for demonstration.
So let's start off with ID,
and
we've got name, which is of type string,
and we've got
email.
So
that is that. An insight query, which is
what I'm gonna be using to make the
request, I'm just gonna call this get user
info.
And
this is gonna be of type user.
So what I can do here is, of
course, I can I can call the entire
list of users? There are 10 users that
are available at the moment. But what I
actually want to do is to actually query
a specific user. So in order to do
that,
as part of this offering, we've got slash
one will give me ID number one. So
if you do a slash ID number,
you get specific information for that particular user.
So I'm just gonna try to map that
over here.
So in order to do that, I'm gonna
add in
parameter.
I'm gonna call it ID.
With that, I'm gonna head on over to
my data sources.
And here, I need to just map out
this particular field. So I'm gonna define my
data source,
call it rest.
The URL is gonna be,
I'm just gonna take the first half first.
And here, because the ID is gonna be
dynamic, so I'm gonna map this using
my ID argument.
So if you just start with a curly
bracket, if you just add a curly bracket
to begin with, it'll give you a choice,
drop down choices of the IDs that we've
got.
As you can remember, as part of our
when we were defining it, we had the
ID parameter as part of the argument there.
I can give this a name. I can
call it user
info.
Method here is gonna be get,
and
that should be it. So if I update
this
and update my definition,
we do have an inbuilt playground which I
can make use of. So let me just
test that out here and hopefully,
say, I'm gonna try and make this a
little bit larger so that it's visible. So
I've got my get user info. I'm gonna
call it ID number one,
ID,
name, and email.
Everything goes well. I should be able to
get back that information.
So now imagine what's happening over here is
that we have effectively transformed
a REST
endpoint into GraphQL
without having to write any code whatsoever. We've
essentially configured that through the universal data graph,
which is obviously very powerful to begin with.
And if I were to change this ID
to three, I will obviously get back that
specific information as well.
And I can add on more fields if
I want to. What I want to do
as an extension to this is
as part of every user, the user also
users also have a to dos list.
I can access based on user slash ID
slash to dos. So this is something that
I'm just gonna
try and replicate at the moment. So I
want as part of so these are two
different endpoints. Right now, they are not really
connected. You have to call this particular endpoint
to be able to get that. What I'm
gonna try to do here
is I am going to
combine
these two different endpoints or information from these
endpoints.
So I've got I'm gonna create a new
object called to do.
Within that, I'm just gonna look at the
fields that are available. I've got user ID,
ID, title, and completed.
Gonna try and map that user ID,
integer,
d is an integer.
I believe
completed
is
boolean.
K.
I want this information to be available. So
when I'm querying a user information, I want
this to be available to me directly.
And for doing that, I'm gonna add in
a field called to dos, and I'm gonna
get back a list of to do, which
is why there is a square bracket there.
So I go into my data sources because
I want to I need to map out
my to dos as well.
I'm gonna define my data source.
I can use the template that I just
created
for the user info, so I can just
use that.
Get rid of this now
because what we're gonna be using here is
this, the ID of the type user,
which is object ID
and to dos here.
I'll change the name of my data source
to call it to dos.
Update my field now and update my API
definition.
Go back to my playground,
to dos,
let's say title and complete should
get back all the to dos of that
particular user. So I can obviously change up
my user and get the to dos of
that specific listing. But effectively, what we have
done here is we have combined
two different data sources and created a GraphQL
schema out of that. And now you can
query through that one single endpoint. You can
query both of those different data sources in
a combined manner.
So that is essentially the power of Universal
Data Graph. Of course, we can go further
into this also,
and we can add more data sources. There
is no limit to that.
But right now, I think I'm gonna just
stop here. What I'll do as an extension
to this, of course, is we already have
this endpoint.
I'm gonna show you a little bit about
the security feature aspect as well with a
couple of minutes to go.
One thing that we can do, I'm gonna
switch over to,
let's see, we do have an external playground
as well. So if you want to enable
that, we can enable the external playground
and hit update.
So the way to access this would be,
you use the API URL on top and
slash playground after that. So I'm just gonna
do this.
That loads up,
well, a GraphQL
playground.
And if I were to run my
query once again here, I should get this
back.
Okay. So I'm getting the information back. Now
let me head on over to policies.
So like Andy had mentioned previously, policies essentially
are like they define sort of the rules
of engagement when it comes to your security,
your rate limits,
and all the keys that are created based
on those policies will inherit all of the
settings or configuration that you have at that
policy level. So I'm gonna call it,
let's say, user. So I can I can
select this particular user info here?
Oh, I need to change the format. So
if I go back to my I APIs,
I'm gonna change my authentication type
to authentication token.
Hit update
on the policies,
add policy,
select the API. You can obviously add or
remove APIs if you want. There can be
multiple APIs in there.
I'm gonna hit configuration.
I need to give this a name, so
I'm gonna call it
test
info policy.
Is
never,
but you can choose a shorter time frame
if you want. And that will create my
policy.
Now once the policy has been created, I
can go in and create my key
based on that policy.
Just hit key here,
that's it. Pretty straightforward to do that. If
I head back over to my playground right
now, it should
prevent me from making this available. So I'm
gonna just add in my
diarization header.
Hopefully, this will get me back my information.
So now there is an authentication token that
is gonna be governing this.
One last thing that I want to show
as part of this, because we are talking
GraphQL endpoints, of course, GraphQL endpoints,
unlike REST, they don't just operate at the
HTTP layer, but they are also at the
data query layer as well. So there are
a couple of issues that that brings in,
which is
a, the depth of queries need to be
limited in some cases because you can have
nested queries which could balloon up too much,
that can result in a denial of service
attack, or it could pretty much hemorrhage your
server.
So in order to do that, here you've
got your query depth.
I'm gonna set this to
two,
and the way you look at this is
if you go back to the playground,
well, a hack that I use essentially is
to look at the open curly braces that
sort of gives me how deep we are
at the moment. So right now, we are
at one, two, three levels deep at the
moment. So if I were to go back
and
hit update on this,
because my I've I've set a maximum query
depth to number two,
this is gonna prevent me from going further.
But if I were to get rid of
the to dos part
and go in there, then it'll get me
back my information. So it sort of prevents
me from going too deep if that is
something that needs to be
configured there. That's one thing. I'm gonna reset
that.
And the other aspect is our field based
permissions. Now imagine
you have different APIs because with with GraphQL,
it brings a lot of flexibility to how
you're constructing your schema.
But also equally, it also exposes that information
to clients, and it gives pretty much puts
the onus on the clients to
request information, whatever information that they want. So
to sort of make sure that you're not
exposing things that you don't want exposed to
specific
clients,
you can put restrictions on the fields as
well. So for instance, I can do that
at that entire user level, so I can
deny access to the to do or the
or the user itself,
or I can look at specific fields.
So for instance, if I don't want email
to be available
for a particular user, then I can deny
access to that. So if I hit update
at the moment,
and if I were to hit play, it's
gonna tell me email is restricted on this
user, and I cannot query that information. So
if I would got rid of that, I
will get back my information.
I can also add in to dos because
we got got rid of query depth limiting,
and I can get that information back in
as well.
So that's about it. I think this was
a very, very fast tracked version or introduction
into the Universal Data Graph. Hopefully, this sort
of made sense, gave you a little bit
of a sense of how the dashboard works,
how you can set your policies. You obviously
set your rate limits and things like that
as well in a through this interface.
But I think I'm gonna just stop here
given that we're about
35 in the hour.
Alright. Thank stop sharing.
Oh, he pushed the wrong button.
That does happen, unfortunately. The hang up button
and the stop sharing button are right next
to each other. I have complained to Ecamm
a couple of times. It is not ideal.
We'll get better just a few seconds to
come back.
Maybe.
I hope he's not talking to himself.
Could be.
So how familiar are you with Universal Datagraph,
MB?
Yeah. I'm pretty familiar with it. It was
released about,
I'm not sure now, maybe six months ago.
So it's yeah. We're rolling out. Right now,
you can
stitch together GraphQL,
REST. You can even do SOAP as well,
but the idea is that, actually, we're gonna
be providing resolvers for things like I I
wouldn't like to say what next, but I
wouldn't be surprised if it was something like
Kafka.
Maybe
we'll even provide an SDK for
Tyk users to actually build these themselves as
well. Nice. And there's support for subscriptions
coming in and also Federation Federation Plus subscriptions.
Federation is something that I find really interesting.
I mean, I'm I'm curious, you know, as
you know, me just as a a solo
developer, like, do I have access to universal
data graph? Is it just a UI that's
behind the the paywall? Can I still leverage
some of that functionality? How does that work?
I better have to welcome back.
The hang up button's right next to the
stops the stop sharing button. I'm I'm really
sorry about that.
No worries. So all all the kind of
all that type of capability,
whether you run open source or whether you
run the enterprise edition, We don't
that there's nothing hidden in the gateway from
our open source
consumers, users.
I think with Universal Data Graph, you could
configure it using something like operator,
but it's pretty complicated,
and I think it's one of those things
where that's pretty
well suited to a UI rather than doing
it on the on the command line. Technically
possible.
Like I say, everything, we don't we don't
exclude any functionality
from the from the open
source users in terms of think of it
as runtime capability.
The the licensed product's really providing
a management layer
Nice. That's useful. It provides the UI that's
useful for especially for something like UDG.
It's also got enterprise y features like single
sign on and and and visibility as well.
So open source gateways are great, I think,
if you're working in a small team. But
if you're a large organization
where lots of people are working with with
Tyk, it's useful to have that management layer
layer that exposes everything that's configured to those
different users.
And then there's functions in there where, actually,
if you are working in a big company
with lots of different teams,
there's ways to kind of isolate and segregate
your installation so one team can work on
their APIs,
and another team can work on theirs without
stepping on each other's toes.
Alright. Perfect. Alright. Plenty there for me to
go and play with there. Any any last
words, Anthony, you want to share before we
say goodbye for today?
Besides, try it, Tyk. This is I I
I don't know if I'm I'm hopefully, I'm
audible. There's been a bit of a boo
boo there with, I think, the stop sharing
screen button.
I was like, what what just happened? Because
everything just went blank, but it's all good.
No. This has been fantastic going through going
through our installation process and just seeing somebody
else trying that out as well on a
on a live platform, of course. That's been
quite interesting to to go over.
What I would recommend is if if people
do want to obviously make try this out
themselves,
go ahead. Go over to the doc docs
and try it out for yourself.
If you do want to try out the
cloud trial or the the version that I
showcased to you, you can do that as
well. The installation guide for that is part
of docs. It's very, very straightforward to get
signed up for the cloud trial. I think
right at the moment, it's about fourteen days
that you can try it out for for
free. Then beyond that, I think you you
might have to pay for that.
But it's a very simple way for you
to get started with some of the more
enterprise editions if you want to do that.
But, like, we just went through, the overall
installation of the open source gateway is pretty
pretty pretty simple
as well.
Awesome.
Well, thank you both very much for joining
me today. It's a really cool product.
I'm looking forward to playing with it more,
and I I really appreciate you joining me
and sharing your insights and knowledge along the
way. So we'll leave it there. I'll let
you both get back to your day, and
I'll hopefully speak to you both again soon.
So have a nice one, and thank you
for joining Thank
you. Thanks so much. Thank you for having
us. Bye bye. Bye.